One of the themes we consistently talk about
here at The Rubin Report is why it is important
to judge people as individuals and not as
a collective.
You as an individual are much more than your
immutable characteristics, be it your skin
color, religion or sexuality.
To judge you on those characteristics is actually
what the essence prejudice really is.
Prejudice, of course, means to pre-judge,
so if you look at a Black person, or a Muslim
person, or a gay person, and think you what
they think, or more importantly how they should
think, based on those characteristics, then
you are actually being prejudiced.
Sadly, many of the people who accuse others
of bigotry and racism these days are often
the people who practice this brand of prejudice
the most without even realizing they're doing
so.
Just look at some of the things my friends
Larry Elder, Maajid Nawaz, and Ayaan Hirsi
Ali are called by the so-called tolerant side.
When you look at a group of people and think
you know what they should think or what's
best for them based on those outward characteristics
and not what's going on in their own mind
you not only lock people into your preconceived
notions of what they are, but stifle the voices
of the minorities within these minorities.
This is why the voices of black conservatives
and gay Muslims are so relevant and interesting.
If you really listen to these minorities within
the minority, you will judge these people
on their thoughts, their logic, and their
reason, instead of simply how they look or
who they love.
In a way, the very existence of these free
thinkers within these minority communities
flips identity politics on its head, showing
the flaws of this post modern intersectional
way of thinking.
Just see how quickly those who preach identity
politics turn on black or latino people who
have conservative political beliefs or how
easily they dismiss gays or women who talk
about how they are poorly treated in Islamic
societies.
Identity politics only works if you believe
the most important quality about each of us
are the attributes we are born with, thus
cannot change, rather than the ideas which
we come to learn.
I view this twisted ideology as a true existential
danger for the tolerant and liberal, albeit
flawed country that America is.
Martin Luther King Jr's desire for his children
to be judged by the content of their character
and not the color of their skin is being pushed
back on, but it's being done by the people
who purport to be the tolerant ones.
We're continuing our partnership with Learn
Liberty today and joining me is the CEO of
the Thurgood Marshall College Fund, Johnny
C. Taylor.
The organization represents nearly 300,000
students who attend the 47 historically black
colleges in America today.
I heard Johnny speak at an event in Dallas
a couple months ago and was blown away by
his passion and commitment to educating young
people and his desire to move past identity
politics.
We're going to talk about politics, race and
much more.
Has the role of the black college changed
as we've become a more fair and just society?
That's one of many questions I'll ask Johnny,
and I'll only judge him by the content of
his answers, not the color of his skin...